the fight against terrorism continues
with authorities carrying out arrests
and drug seizures sorting attacks and
putting terrorists like Salah Abdeslam
on trial but it's also a financial issue
the European Parliament is already
tackling money laundering and organized
crime but members are now calling for
more ways to investigate and track down
terrorist funding the ultra dismal day
all Texans here the inversion economic
vamos a hacer las torres gemelas nueva
pasado el Turismo de Gran impacto pero
definitely important idea casi artisanal
the main step proposed by Parliament is
to create an intelligence platform that
will Forge better links between
financial institutions intelligence
agencies and the judiciary in order to
cut cash flows to terrorists the
monitoring of anonymous debit cards and
traditional ways of transferring money
such as the informal Arabic custom of
hawala should also be improved no se
trata de acabar con la Habana seen a
significant que aquellos que la realism
Dingaan catalan liberal registro de la
misma manera que tiene moliro registro
los compradores de oro tienen que decir
tiene un regalo ro ke cantidad yad on
the modesty novel this money comes at
least partly from the illicit trade in
goods firearms drugs or cultural objects
Parliament wants to step up the
monitoring of suspicious organizations
involved in this trade members also call
for tighter surveillance of educational
centers and places of worship with
potential terrorist ties
you